[Applause]
yo
break this whole thing down to me so
from what i heard and this is just from
where i get my news dj academics
is dr dre's i get so
i really do bro so dj academics post
this thing that says dr dre's wife
is seeking 3 million a month or 2
million dollars a month
2 million a month she says her monthly
nut is five million
so she's like she's doing him a favor
she's doing him a favor two million a
month
two million a month and from dr dre
even though they signed a prenup yes
they have a prenuptial agreement
now she claims later on he ripped it up
and he was like oh we should have never
signed that yeah every guy does that
after you sign it because they know it
works
you get her to sign it and then later
you go man this is stupid but you got
the copy with the lawyer and
everything's good
so this girl is asking for 2 million a
month
now can somebody make the argument
for why she deserves it the only thing i
can say that's like emotional
and okay i can't argue with you is she
said he was abusive if that's true and
there's there's multiple allegations
from other girls to make you think it
might be yeah i can't tell you you don't
deserve whatever money it's gonna
sustain her
lifestyle too though yeah but like but
this is my issue with you
even if i give you that okay he was
abusive take whatever money
[ __ ] him this guy's a monster this list
is so lazily put together
all you had to say is the guy beat me i
want my money [ __ ] him i would be with
that
why do you get money for getting beaten
yeah that's what i'm saying i don't see
why you try to justify that with money
i'm saying even if even if we're willing
to let's say we're willing to give you
this me
2 million [ __ ] that's incentivizing
girls to get beat
maybe you think about it bro maybe he
was okay with the price tag maybe he's
like all right
i'll give him two million a month so two
million a month
think about that they're what prize
fighters don't make that
what if the prize fighters could fight
floyd had to fight
[ __ ] mike tyson in his his
prime like that's not that's a that's a
different weight class you know what i
mean
fighters are very specific about who
they fight but one of them gets knocked
the [ __ ] out
if ronda rousey had to fight whoever the
[ __ ] she would do it for two million
guaranteed
who's this boy tyson fury she would do
it for two million and then you'd be
like yeah that's that's about how much
i'm just saying i don't understand the
beating just because he beat her she
deserves money
i think she deserves money if for the
kids like if somebody raises your kids
for you
yeah i think they deserve money even if
you have a prenup like
once we have kids throw that [ __ ] out we
got to work something else out you can't
raise my children and then i don't feel
like
i have to give you some sort of money i
don't have to raise my child i can go
out and make this money
because i know there's someone i trust
and love raising my children you deserve
something
so say read out some of the things this
is my issue this list laundry and
cleaning ten thousand dollars a month is
too crazy
close 135 000
a month let me ask you a question if
you're spending 135 000 a month
how are you get cleaning clothes you're
getting brand new clothes every month
how long do you change this is going to
sound [ __ ] up but you're reading this
list and you're like
i kind of see
that's because he the way he's shopping
i'm just saying you read the list no
no no you decide to
marry her and everything else and then
that's no
that's not worth it what if she sparked
that time
here's a list 135 000 a month on clothes
then 10 000 a month on laundry that's
off the rip that's craziness okay
if you're spending 135 000 a month on
clothes you don't need to do laundry
exactly throw the clothes that's what
that's what blows my mind
education 60 000 a month [ __ ] are you
buying harvard
720 000 a year for education
no education on earth is that expensive
if you get two million dollars a month
you don't need education know you write
about the [ __ ]
education for you you made all the money
the money's made how much is that a year
24 million dollars a year 24 million
dollars here you don't need to go back
to school
you're an idiot if you go back to school
and you're making 24 million
that's your education don't go to school
don't go to school i figured
let's just slice all the [ __ ] we don't
need a slice you don't need laundry and
cleaning because you got 135 000
a month in clothes you good education
you're 24 million a year
you're good entertainment 900 thousand
dollars a month
what the [ __ ] you doing for nine hundred
thousand dollars yeah what kind of eyes
watch shut parties are you having
you were not that in fact they do have
the mask those are the best parties hey
bro
let me tell you something if you tell me
you spend 900 000 a month on
entertainment i think you're trafficking
human beings this [ __ ] is taken
looking at women behind a [ __ ] glass
and then just bidding on them dude
they're hiring snoop dogg to come to the
house and perform in person
that much snow said that 900
000 a month in entertainment
how boring is dr dre
boring a husband is dr dre that your
wife
needs to spend a million dollars a month
to keep her
[ __ ] entertained man is she not going
to spend none of that on some
ducking and bobbing and weaving classes
or something like that
she put we don't see no karate we don't
see no mma
they're boxing therapy therapy's a good
one
charitable contributions your charity
true he is donating two million dollars
a month to battered women
that ain't enough now and you spend more
on clothes than you do on charity and
you're making two million a month
that's a lot you look wild greedy with
that that's a lot that's a lot terrible
donations 125 000 is a lot i'm not
knocking charity because you know give
back
but that's a lot that's a lot of give
back that's a lot to give back
honestly if you spend a 900 000 a month
on entertainment and 125 000 a month on
charity you're kind of a piece of [ __ ]
you can't hurt
a thousand oh [ __ ] that's right you're
kind of greedy you're spending seven
times as much or whatever doctor rid
yourself with this toxic queen
this girl's spending all your goddamn
money only mostly i even put that
together
that's why it's called beats by dre i
was trying to figure it out
900 000 entertainment
we're gonna need some noise cancelling
for everybody in this community
yo i never put that together until
right now yeah yo what's it called the
secrets are always in the images what
does q anon say
anyway mortgage is a hundred thousand
dollars a month which is
insane a hundred thousand dollars a
month how are you spending more on
clothes than a house sunset
a hundred thousand dollars a month
mortgage is not as crazy as the other
expenses no it's crazier that's probably
the only expense that i can understand
if they live in
a gigantic house due to math like
gigantic
taylor do this math for me 100 000 a
month
or you could do this math 100 000 a
month is 1.2 million dollars a year yes
times 30 if you do a 30 year fixed 36
36 million home you need to live in
you need to live in a 36 million dollar
home he
got like almost 700 m's from that
beats deal with apple like he came real
close to being
the first hip-hop billionaire so what
there are 36 million
poems and if you're a billionaire that's
not that crazy i will say that's crazy
but that's not the craziest one the
craziest one is the next one read the
next one
tell explain to me how this is
mathematically possible cell phone
email twenty thousand dollars i don't
understand why email costs anything i
know
what email is she using the aol cds let
me tell you something you've got
dialogues
makes noise we got the fastest internet
a human being can have what is it
200 a month tops 200 a month 200
tops what kind of iphones you buy it
every day there's twenty thousand
a month she got this yo you know what's
wrong
125 000 in terrible donations per month
right
the girl who does her laundry and
cleaning only gets 10 crayons
real talk think about that you got
potentially illegals
that need all that charity and they only
get in ten thousand maybe he's hiring
the husbands to play mariachi for them
or something that'd be fire if they did
that
yeah this is an absurd list somebody
must have made up this list this can't
be real
it can't be there's no way this is
anything the list might be made up but
the request
if it's your lawyer fire that guy so
here's my here's my curiosity with like
how this divorce hearing [ __ ] goes
are you just supposed to throw out a
stupid number and then you never gets
there
i think i think it's a settlement it's
an out-of-court settlement especially
with rich people
this also could be a [ __ ] you of to dr
dre of
i'ma ask for 2 million a month and i'm
gonna get close to it and i'm not even
gonna try
i'm gonna put together the dumbest
[ __ ] list you ever seen in your life
because [ __ ] you i'm taking a bunch of
your money you piece of [ __ ]
twenty thousand a month for my cell
phone yo you know what she could be
brilliant you might be right